sometimes yell [ __ ] ready why did you
start the show guys sometimes like I
don't have the strength to move forward
and I would die and I was feeling really
good and then all the wind was taken out
of my sail Mike Tyson no I'm glad you
asked why it's not because of Mike Tyson
we still have on the show but we must be
on the show we've been idea backs well
member Lee and he had hip back surgery
and he's a little croc anyone to
reschedule but we don't reschedule you
had a set time we love him and we would
love him to love our love we're not
going to do it later because well we're
too cool now that's not why Evander
Holyfield's called he called him you
didn't like another win for Evander I am
NOT okay why are you bothered why do you
hold my phone because I'm looking at the
boots that you're going to spend way too
much money on spent you bought these
already but I didn't I won't show you a
picture of you know store this is why I
wear I really all wonder it Lawrence I
they're coming from here called efz
alcohol no they drop these just to get
ice Sanna home why yourself for the kids
out there yeah
say hello wrong so Brennan decided to
buy these these beige suede is our home
boots that have buckles it there's a
buckle it's there's a there's a there's
a buckle you know what I think on it I
think they're Game of Thrones inspired
heel it's so high that the only thing
these would go is the only thing these
would go with is a [ __ ] miniskirt oh
now you're talking yeah and I I can
barely take it's like this is just to
had to metrosexual hey you can wear
these I'm gonna be wearing those all the
tunur so what we're not I know anything
is fancy boots I decided I won't be that
guy who I go jeans shirt conclude it you
know I'm saying like no I don't know
what you're saying why is it so [ __ ]
so I'm slowly rubbing off in leather so
when I met you you come a studio in
sweats and sandals now elekid a socks
alexander these common projects are
comfortable is all balls I'm rubbing off
on you
yeah
Varro's to boot New York LA boots love
them desert out there black spinel DS
not for you yes I wish you there now
those are the those are the McLaren of
shoes they're not for me because my name
isn't Jennifer and I don't I can't give
birth
all right Saint Laurent's just for to
listen and I wish yeah I really don't
mind if you if you want to say is I want
to come out on the spot do it there's a
few things I want to ask you about
calmly I'm the gotiya I am we go Ana
County I'm going yet yeah
Venice coffee I'm going to Brian yeah go
right wine wine I'm going to brush yeah
fashion why not play nice keys right not
long piece by now okay well I learn you
well Brian ah when my Invisalign takes
out in six months if I keep wearing them
which I haven't really not listen to
that straight teeth not going to Brian
okay you won't say like follow learn how
to drive a car just going to say man try
this on a listen I find goes hey bro
your teeth aren't that straight try this
I'm gonna [ __ ] you [ __ ] out you know
your pride goes hey bro I like to wear
those shoes look you strive you in two
point and I see no show you [ __ ]
there two points not all right doesn't
hey man I like that bit I would button
it with this I go oh thanks be her you
know what you're talking about her
listen I'm if you go hey bro I watch you
box when you throw your jab you should
duck shut your mouth o matter watching
COC fight which guys I wish the
fundamentals shut your mouth okay sir
okay
I understand not be killed man that car
was cool it sounded like it had shut
your mouth I don't want hear about cars
either if we're in the weight room and
open and you're deadlift technique shut
your mouth all right now for round
cheese from cheese all right yeah I'm
alright gotta taste it right you're
gonna taste sure well I'm going to taste
it so don't let a museum and there's
some lame [ __ ] like that for some
lame paintings and you want to give me
the history of the 18th century
imma listen yeah now brother football
games yeah and I see I see a fumble you
go man I got [ __ ] up I'm looking your
[ __ ] your mouth
alright ok clear words so cheese yeah
cheese wine wine
history history museums museums and
sucking dick no no on tennis I'm coming
at it and well not really tennis hit sir
no nothing else sir if I may
here's the problem and I'm going to give
you a fashion tip these are very pointy
they be sold as super thin heel is super
high and they have a buckle on now I
have but I am allowed to also talk about
all things man
man you're not let's just go sir
illiterate man nobody not men sir you
you boxer and tennis player hey let's
learn new [ __ ] [ __ ] no no no [ __ ]
no de you bang let's go over here shitty
history teacher not horrible dentists
not cheese expert you cheese expert wino
wino con artists okay maybe I'll Connor
but also okay okay ran although ran
although she's a night like no man know
if there's a nice cheddar cheese yet
wheel come you guys and you only give me
your expertise on it yeah I'll listen
yeah I also listen yeah but I'll never
which I was rooming you are Charlotte
dive off big K I'm cool and do that
stuff bro why you making me the dick
diver why you making me the dick dive
expert you doing I've a really no dick
diver built on its gonna dig that with
these solo home that's us nobody diving
nobody should wear boots with a name
like Sandow home who makes those boots
send a home right there means that you
you live for car almost faster news I
know micro you don't - oh you're -
nieces all your fashionistas oh yeah
friends you're fashionistas be you dive
on God you rob you dig done you did that
read you live for God hate these out of
my entries when I get eat tourney bag
and dick I just told you the Johnny mean
still dig every time I look at does I
want to suck a dick now listen bro
that's what girls say to my bottom don't
wear those - I told those boots what dig
divers because when girls seem died on
you listen girls like a stain you know
what girls so when I see your teeth what
dick run no they don't do it because my
teeth are getting better and I can
you like guys doing this you tease hey
your Dino head but your teeth are no
great shakes either bro compared to
yours now compared to your a phablet to
cover them up
forget the fact that true if you if I
pulled your libido and yours not real
sir are not real in my teaching my piece
is like the crust comers I have one
[ __ ] issue one I got one bad boy
right back here my feeling of one I have
one [ __ ] tooth that's being brought he's
being disciplined and brought into line
while the other one is take like the
rioting don't ya oh your last of them
are going
so are you have you looked at your front
teeth you're lucky you got them big dsls
because I can't see much you're so into
dick dive into me
listen may be honest hey be honest do
did you buy the Rolex sea-dweller so you
can dick diver have the sea-dweller are
you a do you watch not a toy I leave you
why Jacque Cousteau documentary so you
can pick dive later listen listen listen
women like a thick soul are you buying
these boots put them on when you put
them on in the privacy of home do you go
on I feel like myself
hey dude do you open up every bit and
then everyone's going dick done dick duh
duh do you and then your whole crowds as
guys with their [ __ ] out like this
enables me when your girl walking down
girls gone do you secretly raid her
closet and and squeeze into her on knees
and go I feel like myself it's okay if
you do know oh my god
daddy there was a pause before there's
not no I'm worried about is your dick
diving bottom row teeth do you put you
wear a headscarf sometimes ago I wish my
hair was longer your diet went dry your
dining with to wear a man bun I'm glad
you didn't go that far man bun yeah now
you're Jolin someone you got drama here
Yeah right one please make no mistake
man man you wish man you noon actor
pretend to be a man bro I box I boxed
yesterday in boxing today
sparring sparring buh-buh-buh captain
shot
answering back [ __ ] answering bat and
because the locker rooms can dive on
their dip then one of the guys I sparred
with is very gay but a very long so gay
man yes how do you know he's gay because
he talks about it like what you say well
Wayne McCulloch likes to tease him and
he's been training him a long time and
he's he's a very successful producer
handsome man very muscular and gay and
will punch you in the face and then take
your ass away from you take your ass
he's not and by the way yes yeah he'll
take your ass away from you he's not
he's not a guy who steal your head he
doesn't take he doesn't take it he gives
it there are differences you know that's
like my buddy's my buddy Keith I told
you that sorry my buddy Keith whose yeah
boyfriend he gives it and I asked him
one time I go have you ever you know
taken it and he goes what and I go you
know with with your boy did he ever give
it to you and he goes hey I don't do
that [ __ ] bro like dead serious dude he
was Harvard and I go why is that I go I
go he goes I don't do that I go oh I
know you were gay homophobe but that's
cool uh because he's not into that he
doesn't do that and there are a lot of
gay men that I know glom on to come out
and they just they they don't get their
butts taken they they like two bad guys
and to me I don't know how gay that is
that might be so straight that you have
to have guys now like if you're if you
have a boyfriend that you hold down and
you you have to you own pile him yeah
it's almost like like those are guys
that I like like I never feel like I'm
around anybody gay when I'm around him
or you know like he's just like
macerator [ __ ] ah I don't think so he's
an amazing guy
my Tolman dude no he's an amazing guy he
does he says that stuff he'll be like
here's the difference with me go really
deep voice macho he's like guys at one
time I was with Frank Grillo and he
loved dragon with like some guys bet he
loves and he's hanging out he can talk
about everything he'd fire everything I
mean he's made millions of dollars he's
a macho dude big strong guiding us and
finally just cuz he ever hears the
difference for me and you guys I suck
[ __ ] so Scott oh really
oh hold on hold on so he will suck dick
but he won't suck your [ __ ] sucking [ __ ]
but if [ __ ] a guy kiss me I kiss God
deep and hard and true you hold him in
the back hold the back of his head and
drink deeply of his lips so here's a
strange yes but then it turned you over
and you pick spot on that [ __ ] pillow
because he's going to town he's not stop
until he's done and that's how it is and
his boyfriend is very smooth very smooth
little fairy
it will phone with a blood he's Filipino
he's got a [ __ ] bubble butt and a
beautiful chest he's actually from Burma
and he is he looks like the letter S
it's where I came up with he's just got
all these all Assam tits small hazard
he's not that small he's he's got a very
good looking guy he has a little clip on
the top of his ear he wears his hair
over one eye and he is as feminine and
as just as pretty and smooth with a full
mouth he be I'm sure he feels fantastic
to me to be involved in I mean he's got
a great mouth and no promise face and
I'm not homophobic at least Obama
uncomfortable right well cuz you're a
certified dick diver and you keep
talking about don't call me a certified
pig diver don't call it easy
DD you don't call me a c DD Breaux I
don't know where this came from you turn
this around on me
you got these [ __ ] saw the hall boots
and suddenly I'm a CVD yeah use a tiny
brush certified big door open hood
what's going on other cannibal was we
responded with Steve we're supposed em
we were supposed to have mike tyson and
now i'm being fitted for a waterproof
pressure resistant watch i gotta hope
i'm and he's putting slippers on me i
got a dry suit on there's a water tube
in a boat I don't know what's going on
now in just a patch for your ass Nemo
that big old patch for my ass and my raw
CDD mass or my dick diver yeah Mike
Tyson with a I told if he could call the
next two hours we'll have him on but
hopefully I'll call my cats on him and
hear the podcast come out here's a book
coming up your phone on let's see what
happens uh podcast he's got a podcast in
the book we can promote it um yeah there
it is we promoted it would you I'm
getting on taking a red-eye tonight I
can't wait what I like to do you know
the 10:30 fine to Charlotte then I do
press at 6:30 in the morning oh but I
could perform there's the press when you
do those things Peggy here was Brian
Kelly you guys might remember from that
TV and Modern Family I'm not Modern
Family I'm sorry that's right you're on
yeah you're on the gold brother gold
brings a concept I was over you but you
guys would know this guys you can see
them right now I'm staring I'm right now
we got Brian Kells I hear here he is
everybody Brian give it up for my man
Brian right are you doing North Carolina
that's literally how I'm introduced
today go
you know what dude you're one of those
guys like I don't know you by name but
when I see you I'm like I know that guy
dude I got him let me do some he's funny
he's fine he will be at Just for Laughs
this Saturday night he'll be out so he
goes that's right he'll be at the ready
zone Thursday Friday Saturday all that
stuff jeongja tickets matter of fact
we're gonna wait for tickets right now
call into cares 107 five right now for
number seven seven three to seven times
where was Bryan Callen from the
Goldbergs I think that's great and it is
a great leading nervous that's everyday
just every DJ and there but they there
for the morning before horrible hours so
they look exhausted econ no I shot you
really cool but I don't know how they
wake up at 3:00 in the morning it's so
bad for you and they just show up
quickly you aged hard man in sight I
don't know I feel I feel like ever do
that job I feel like those jobs are not
a dying breed they are because you can
how many people actually listen to the
radio in the morning when you're driving
you know but not really Morgan or not
that's right we're bored well now you
get your own music at your own playlist
there's Pandora Spotify iTunes music yet
Apple yeah Sirius now you got podcasting
I don't I'd be interested to see and you
should look in this because I'd like to
stop doing them you should look into it
to see how far their reach goes yeah
well good all be crazy Brendon job
listen we saw Brian we have 100
listening well you know what sage demo
well these are about 70 to 90 years old
to listen to so no you're so right about
this because actually now what's
happened is to make money have to
syndicate so so there's no point in
doing any kind of local press the only
time you do local press is like for
example in Charlotte where they have
local radio stations that are still
listening to buy it buy a lot of the
population and that's what they tell you
they're connected yeah well we'll save
we'll see we'll see what happened - yeah
- come on Charlotte tomorrow Bryan
Callen one night one night
- so Friday - so Saturday get your
tickets immediately and CLT comedies on
or T fat K calm North Carolina the
Carolinas or they've good riddance to
fortune I like short worse Haley today
we're silly geese hey North Carolina's
ultimate pig divers come to your town
he's got his he's got his Mariner his
Rolex mariner freshens up mentors on its
ready to dive do you and you things out
this guy does not care what you look
like he does not care how old you are as
long as you are of age this guy's a
crazy dick sucker must have a deep rod
because he likes to dive deep he dives
deep get out your snorkels boys
ah man I don't know what's going on with
us today oh boy yeah busy week next week
you're in my trail I start my tour so we
had a bank some podcast don't ya brother
we got a bank some pods I wish were
coming to Montreal I won't lie dump
David all its going to be very low we're
gonna be there I know but you know
you're doing a thing yeah um are you
excited about your dates are you excited
about going all these places to be in my
celiac you see yeah I coffee lookin very
high Kyle it was called the money tour
the money flight Taurasi know cuz i
break down carmel that stuff no it's
called the don't die tour does that feel
like I'm gonna die cuz you're coming off
sided I'm just yeah it's that the open
job is why kill your ladies one is what
kills you
yeah the time the time difference yeah
Australia was a toffee yeah but I feel
like England been fine to England from
New York I'm flat and I'm I'm not in New
York I go I go I go straight from so I
go this week it kicks off it goes
Phoenix Salt Lake Aztec sold out and
then next week it goes Toronto hashtag
sold out Toronto Detroit Chicago
oh I'm sorry goes Toronto Chicago
Chicago only one would take its left
then it goes
Detroit sold out which is on a Sunday
Wow check this out are you done with
Detroit I fly back to LA for the day so
I can see my son and Joe and then that
night take a red-eye from
way to England well that's terrible
that's going to be that's terrible
and I think that flight and I've done it
is is it 8 or 11 hours and make it to 11
hours
it's unbounded honestly yeah he'll get
my rescue sweetheart I almost want it
longer so I can des yeah I'm sleeping
this New York London in New York was
five hours yes not that yeah I used all
my points to fly first class it was a
waste because you have a bed in this
shitty playing five no is it - five
hours five hours I got [ __ ] I know like
satin coach with no pride no right if
that shave your points yeah I know you
know but then I yes so then I go la to
London two or three shows in London once
you're in Manchester and then six - that
wells I've ever been who would have
thought I'm comedy we brought me around
neck raised the old glue the old flack
loan old flatty he also had a hilt flat
flat I was this listening to the set and
big the ancient Greeks who figured out
the earth was [ __ ] around because
they would just take a pole this is the
other thing that Eddie and those guys
should kind of like just to a little
leading to see like what your ancestors
your forefathers and you know did before
you like they would take a pole and they
would just put it in one part of the
field and then put it in another part of
the field and it casts a different
shadow the reason it casts a different
kind of shadows because well the earth
is curved and it could be Sun is going
to hit at a different angle they're
really simple ways and you know I don't
know how you got out all the music all
they figured that out everyone free I
know I even bother with the hilarious I
don't have the energy is I shouldn't
have energy huh what'd you say we're all
doing work what did you say
you just heading up this flat you know
would you really obsession on YouTube or
in arguing with trolls
why would you waste your car tonight
it's exact latter's trolls YouTube and
kind of they're all like this weird kind
of it's a small grid get this idea
they're a big group it's it's not small
yet we want us mom thought you were
smart about us is smart I thought it
made sense like when you said the Alex
Jones thing and you're like he's painted
she's huge phenomenon he gets 60 million
downloads that's not true I'm not buying
any of that no and you were right it's
like a small it's like in his world
is big yeah well you know everybody out
there I'm big in Europe bro yeah I'm
sure you are over here it's not yeah
there's so much [ __ ] going on you know
there's so many ways to also it's really
interesting how you can turn so if you
just come up with a lot of [ __ ] like
this guy
I can't think hizmet at matías Rath I
think his name was he has a vitamin
company and he went into South Africa
and said stop taking all the drugs that
the West is giving you and take my
vitamins you can cure AIDS with turmeric
garlic you know all those stuff and
people started doing it and they in fact
were like I we don't want this Western
medicine and you can create a narrative
which says they just want to make money
off you and make you more sick because
the medication actually makes you gives
you the side effects and stuff and
people love to buy in so when then
you're then the Medical Association goes
this guy's a [ __ ] fraud a liar and
everything else well it's really easy
for you then to say look at how the
Medical Association this whole machine
is against me well I'm the one mad I
told you this was gonna happen told ya
it's happening cuz you're full of [ __ ]
yes yes and you knew it was gonna happen
so you clean it this new that's right
and that's what kind of bad people are
out for themselves will do they'll just
create this narrative you know I mean
it's it's you got have you got to be
able to that's hard to do but you've got
to be able to like you know separate the
wheat from the chaff man I mean there
are certain truths that we know another
said that we don't but but yeah it's
kind of like the it's like the sheep
follow right like this this mass sheep
you're always going to get blip linen
when you have the the admit I would call
she see of the people who actually
educated certainly lads yes I suppose
this one as complete [ __ ] well you
know and there's always that idea people
want to be in an exclusive club that
it's really imply Kuenn you create an
exclusive I we have the truth we have
the knowledge so everybody else doesn't
right yeah but that's kind of what no
our telescope I want to talk about that
I want I don't know the details do you
have a follow this time you'd be follow
follow the doctors like and Rand like
she was a political philosopher of
libertarian and she was at a museum art
I think with the Guggenheim Museum of
Art and she was watching all these
people crowd around like like the guy
had a light bulb and there was a broom
handle and it was art and and
everybody's like wow it's so interesting
she was like what then she went over to
another and there was a canvas it was
literally a white canvas and somebody
bought it for a million dollars Jesus
okay and it was in the Guggenheim and
there was this whole heart movement like
that and then you know so she was like
what's going on here
she couldn't figure it out because it
was complete [ __ ] nonsense of course
we're an outsider to come in but all
these people in the know were like wow
that's so unique and she went I get it
these people aren't interested in the
art what they love is being part of a
really exclusive club that gets it and
nobody else gets it and that's why you
can sell you were able to sell a white
canvas literally for a million dollars
there are some there's some great modern
art of course but there's criteria so
I'm glad you bring this up because we're
starting a fund kid exclusive club for
$9.99 a month $9.99 a month a guy who
several dick pigs that's right and Brian
will dive and he and behind gigi hadid i
some pig diving behind the scenes CDD
action you want to be a CDD get a car
motive dig dive and Watts from fighter
in the kid there it is yeah I don't know
exactly what's going on with our Kelly
but I fly at a Colton like the girls
weren't allowed to talk to the family
and stuff with this one your current
vention yes should we just dick diving
these current event current events out
have you heard about this though I I
just saw that it said our Tilly has
cult-like yelling here's my first
question you might know this why was he
let off after he can sing on those
Andrew I thought you pissing on a young
girl for your dog the video of it first
of all your career is over right and
you're over but and you're going to jail
and he wasn't so what happened he's
bigger than ever I well I will easy on
bigger than ever I don't know he's not
bigger than ever
okay so why did he get off do we know
why I think the girls that were it's
convinced and said there's video on this
consent like they won the pistol weren't
they 14 more than 13 so I think he just
had a lot of money and was able to win I
was really kind of certain piss on a
thirteen-year-old yeah this is just he
has like a harem of young women and he
kind of controls their their
communication with the outside world and
go with it this is what he's accused of
a BuzzFeed report said that
and then it's their parents the girl's
parents that are fighting him right now
so it is a part of Kelly's entourage
Cheryl Mac Kitty Jones and Asante McGee
Wow
santé McGee he's a king but there might
be you know whenever I see the stuff I'm
always like what role of the girls are
the girls into they [ __ ] like oh my
goodness
hey Beezus just to ask for food you have
to ask to go to the bathroom
yeah a master at mind control he's a
puppet master tonight now his truck down
his his clicks the real dig divers well
so so how about this so I told this is
sick but I know of eret there's a very
famous woman well she would now I'm
sorry she was a public figure and I knew
her in fact she kind of liked me a
little bit and I was almost gonna date
her and she was a friend of a friend
do I go nope but I'll tell you it later
she but she used to date a very powerful
when I met her she had just been broken
up with by this very powerful man okay
you would everybody would know and uh my
buddy who is really good friends with
her he's gay and stuff and he was like
all right I'll tell you something you
cannot [ __ ] tell anybody I go what he
goes you have to promise me and and I've
never told anybody who it was until but
I'll tell you after this I'm telling you
miss miss this guy is this crew this guy
she was really intelligent she was like
she's like you know really intelligent
really successful type-a person a lot
the whole thing I remember being really
flattered that she dug me you know and I
remember we're talking to her and I was
pulling out you know I'm I'm a con
artist I'm pulling out all my reading
all my you know I could hug Ling I'm
charmer right I'm charming man man
charming man man he's on the man stuff
man
boxer tennis flirtin Deep Diver wrestler
xiii hmm dig man
des I'm saying that but anyway I'll talk
to her so he's dead check this out this
what he used to do to her he would make
her drink either like five beers or five
cokes and then he would uh make her sit
and when she had to go to the bathroom
she had to pee really badly he'd be like
she'd be like like pee need be like No
I'm really going to pee my pants and you
go I don't give a [ __ ]
sit there and then he would pull his
dong out and as he said one time she was
you know go out of town and he goes look
at me
she looks up at him and he goes back and
he slaps her really hard and puts her
back down on his dog I told the girl
that I was dating you looking wrong I
thought the girl was gonna go oh my god
I swear to God shoot without Miss Julie
tell me that story i watch what David
tell me that does she really goes oh
yeah tell me that's right guys yeah and
then he pulls diggin slapped a fat hot
no ha like what hold on yeah anyway
sounds like some more attention yeah
then he would let her pee and then he'd
make her drink some more and she'd have
to sit there and that was their thing
that was their game he was a [ __ ] oh
sorry here we go I'm sorry he would keep
her in the closet
he tired of the thing she's hiding into
it this she's - she's hydrated you know
what I would do
obviously the first time you're gonna
get me I can't piss a young wait to tell
me yeah second third time soon I'm like
I got a piss
already I just fool him you know yeah I
feel like I piss really bad yeah you
heard him get done with it yeah that's
you she was into this obviously this was
obviously an owner kept things there's
these weird role-playing that people do
that are you know and that powerful man
was me and so this is the first time I
was I didn't see a lot of sand is
getting off my chest
give them yeah I would I would feed her
maybe worse eat like I eat a lot of
chili a lot of chili some pork chops and
when you're ready to bust one of us I
mean when you get a little do you're not
pulling it ain't happenin you're gonna
wear this plug hearing where this glass
butt plug and then I will be the one to
pull rank on you know that exist - you
wish playboy so that sound like some are
Kelly's [ __ ] this is what's sad though
the girl says the text read to her mom
one of the girls in his entourage put I
hate Christmas has to be this way this
year happy Mother's Day from me and Rob
I'll see his first name's Rob It was as
if she was brainwashed she looked like a
prisoner prisoner of dick it was
horrible I hugged her and hugged her but
she kept saying she's in love with Kelly
and he is the one who kissed her I don't
know what to do I hope that I get her
back
Jesus I can get her treatment for
victims of cults they reprogrammed her
but I wish I could stop it you know it
van munchin syndrome no no Stockholm
Syndrome yes
stock up all over love with their cap
you fall out of your captors Stockholm
Syndrome is a very real thing you fall
in love with your captors and after a
while you you will you will volunteer
Chris paying them yeah and you won't
leave you know that 2008 tell you was
acquitted of all charges in J engage in
sexual act with a minor which was on
video you're playing that video I
haven't I didn't want to walk in here so
it is their video this DJ hit me what if
we're really hosting the video near now
what do you want to see it cuz she's
yeah I don't want no I wish to unity
that's not watching hey man shame shame
head chin and I'm just a computer we're
closer in age have you see the video
yeah of course you are some it's very
beautiful today you always are but you
look very similar if art Kelly is like
listen girl I don't know what the [ __ ]
Brian Bennett paying you but join the
club
would you like try it out for
interesting would you be our insider and
then like would be finding the kid like
we got a semi live from our code ah what
happened last night when we're all
around
we got plastic bags out and make a
shitload of electrolytes and just piss
all over us but I was wearing camera
rocks no I wouldn't let that [ __ ] happen
you would you be up for that all proudly
Queen I didn't take that how mad would
your parents be pretty good disappointed
more than any I've ever guess who
participated have you ever dated a
celebrity no nothing is it which
celebrity would you date crazy [ __ ] who
Jones all 84 years old no way get on the
mic we can't hear hey Quincy wheel [ __ ]
is Quincy who auntie no not gonna be
John Quincy I did you son bring him up P
Diddy son pull them on well cheer girl I
might better make that happen
yep bring over teaching he's I think 25
or 26 day upper a quenching
he's like we got your girl right here
and she's beautiful
Quincy he did he said he's a cute kid
man oh you know what I have seen this
gentleman he was a medicine it's not his
axe we're help I seen a movie on uh my
lived on my dream for sweet 16
I knew it well I know that I'm yeah he's
a handsome devil he's a handsome devil
now he's a stepson
yeah his stepson so he was real did uh
Albie he's a singer is you seen his mom
zamata so he was she was a supermodel in
New York
damn he's a really good-looking and he
is same age he's like two three years
older is he a big deal amongst the
kiddos uh kind of not really like I feel
like the my super sweet 16 helped him
and then the fact that dude is he doing
kuru she know I'm a fan of her who's
kuru she tangent adorable I saw her
while I was driving to rowing this on
her Mercedes really supposed to Grove
she is don't you said it you talk about
definition delicious Easy's essential
kid don't ever put your hair in braids
like that ever again and looked at and
looked at sincere at us you Khalil you
don't know who that is
you cool um what's he do besides the
severest Prince now just seems and he
just started his singing career did he
have any songs out uh yeah he just said
he did a show in LA ending Janet let's
uh critique this young man can you find
him on iTunes please I'd like right here
music wouldn't you Brian
I would hello he's got to be on YouTube
right yeah how would you say hell's to
the yeah you know sauce thing I think
it's brown not sure
Quincy and he's a singer or rapper or
what a singer oh they're just good to
stay for a while let's hear this I want
you to could take this alright first of
all like into sincerity I already like
the shoe kind of all I thought up
he said million views backers girl
okay not mad at the girl in the picture
shouldn't be and I said that he looks a
little different let's go over the short
hair I think this is wrong do you think
what I think this one's a little old
that his hair is longer now okay like I
have shades on them doors I don't
approve of that I've read I didn't do
that
Oh
[Music]
you think it's naturally a singer he's
not thinking he's at him singing or else
like him yes ma'am
it might be a little both go ahead just
jump in though Quincy whenever you wants
your song son just kind of dive in now
didn't see a dick and dive on in like
Brian game yeah dive on yes let us wait
keep us waiting
yeah you wait until you bird hurry rod
oh come on Alice just kid at all never
heard of them but I'm into it our summer
kind of about the bust as far as I get
bigger now
I felt like it'll take a while but the
fact that Diddy's is done
how much can we get away with this chin
chin you know how about doing music do
you know who kids nah
do you think he's any good bounds good
chin yeah straight up are you better
than him we're just different ah
we're just Everett oh [ __ ] dude I got a
start I gotta get some jewelry here's
the pink dolphin uh flow clothing on
this from 2012 Wow not the most current
one chin strap five years a cloud of all
the guys heat that's him huh no summer
let's keep my favorite for a while uh
you've been dipping even like it was
here on oh my god oh how old is he is
last month how old is he the song's
called 17 he's not 17 is he cute oh god
not I was like damn I saw loose women in
gene women ng I did a disc instead of
this I got it
I did a photo shoot in jeans in a pool I
remember it was bit of a beast you sent
me at the montage yeah I remember I was
written long time ago written well you
know Christ's sake somebody's got to do
it that's why you're getting out good
whatever you're getting out in here
[ __ ] t-shirt
his voice is very synthesized process
dad you know I'm thanks that always
tells me like good dystrophin will do a
lot of weird ends nuts click on the
bottom right there that one chin yeah he
is brazen it's really bothering oh it's
got that old Corvette - and the two
[ __ ] hey bro what Bravo yeah I don't
know how the work I don't know how it
goes I'm just trying to be cool hey did
you like it when a series like this or
summer in my life I ain't afraid I like
it when it you want to like a gangster
face you pull that back or cut it off oh
man I was on board
Oh st. Laurent jacket is wearing
unfortunately that big one is right
there you know what's tough about being
a musician stop it you know about be a
musician like this is especially like I
feel like like like R&B is that you've
got to be so cool like you got to be so
sensual and cool you can never have a
sense of humor it feels like like that's
just a lot of work man
you know what I mean you got to look
passionate you got to look sultry sexy
you got to be clueless yeah so it's like
[ __ ] off never hard
nobody really feel about all the guys
are some of him huh I'm he's like you -
don't get me wrong but that's him yes it
is
I'm not mess up what I call that the
wild card pick now if he showed up in
that in that long trench coat a trench
coat and braids mm great maybe not the
braids killed him
I like yeah he pulled him back over his
head maybe but [ __ ] in your eyes it's
like dude you got you like like through
your ass baby I do like that look I like
to you right I gotcha
ah [ __ ] it all beer trap you set me up
you set me up making a case for you be
an official dick diver just add da you
just [ __ ] set me up you you i gen
love it you know when you have a
gladiator of ten yeah you dig die you
get me not you you set a trap don't send
anymore dick tower traps
like we never know those don't go the
podcast all right bro don't set any more
chances I don't like that [ __ ] a man all
right I'm trusting you not to all right
I'll try all the show goes all right
Mayan gotten Hayden hates EDD traps
that's the random picker so how do we
even get on this all eyes are jelly it
was your grand plan to get me in a trap
you brought it Brad I was at 7:00 she
joined our Kelly's try I'm still part of
your trap it was all it's been a long
master plan don't set your trap here
come please I'm gonna trust you all
right I'm gonna trust you hi bro you go
to gym today yes yeah you Boston I'm
gonna do some boxing man I'm excited I
have to cool it you bought your boss a
guy uh right yeah you said a big guy
yeah the guy I did the man is gay the
gay gentleman here yeah I'm in a box in
hand uh we're gonna move around what we
are doing afterwards women I was just
curious what you
hey you're not setting a trap are you no
I'm just kind of like you know some guys
like when are you done Boston I liked it
I don't take a shower yeah hit the
streets and then go your coffee yeah you
know what and then I was like you guys
you get done shine and yeah I'll take a
shot and then like you stay in the sauna
yeah well so what I'll probably do is
I'll take a shower or maybe I'll just
maybe I'll retire to the sauna yeah
retire me and then you see in the - yes
sometimes he gets in there and you know
I never talk to you ever Donna it's so
yeah I bet you do talk but does ever get
like she does he make it like super hot
in there yeah I've been a lot of fun
yeah it gets super just real hot because
you want it really hard to penetrate
your muscles you asking me well I'm just
curious because you make it so hot
really can't really see it gets super
it's got super super like body in there
yeah and like then you're like dripping
wet yeah you body your body the sweat
just pours off you I will say that
that's why I get in now it feels not as
even though just to tell am i right well
I mean if I say this no come on I've
been in a million saunas you just did
some towels it's not hot there are there
there have been times I can trust you
bro there have been times where I've
taken the towel off sure sure I need to
chisel
he took his off he does
oh you led me down the back oh god I
knew it
Paul my throne above the Garbo may we're
cup of silly
honk-honk-honk goose I'm a goose Oh Hulk
sorry man
I scream I have a heavy what don't she
had Jim cook the [ __ ] are we doing bro
come on Jen more current events I got
for him see what uh my boyfriend
let me see oh we got an email oh man did
go on a strict diet my publicist okay we
just booked your campaign and be
shirtless in a few weeks
great let the dick diver be there gonna
be a shirtless that's what he said
congratulations I can just see you
dieting now well it's the water okay oh
boy you're gonna be a bad crowd you know
what I like to do man I like to watch
Game of Thrones about the halfway
through season two now okay okay
I bought the boots because the game of
Thrones and yep sometimes post lace is
right there the delivery whatever your
heart desires yeah alpha doesn't
doughnuts maybe lies out you did did you
beat a natural death sandwich did you
eat that much that was your JP ice cream
you got a little crazy I've well I
caught cheat Game of Thrones night
really every night well then I had pink
eyes like I feel sick I'll run in the
morning yeah you didn't do it I did do
it or you did run them on it did do it
that's a lot of doughnuts brother six
and ice cream you binge you tend to
binge and what happens in your mind you
go you know what [ __ ] it you know I'm
gonna start with one doughnut no in the
beginning I'll go just you you deserve
it you've earned it do it [ __ ] it and I
eat a map I go you [ __ ]
I know a guy who has an eating issue you
know and he will go and buy for Big Macs
and then three apple pies and then look
at them and throw them away
Neos Circle the block but the guy time
is fat at least some in shade since
Cairo yes and he'll go by this I say six
hundred pounds were talking about yeah
by five Big Macs six apple pies throw
two of them away but then eat the other
ones ten you have kind of Wendy's do the
same thing I wish this guy didn't tell
me that the shoot coming up and go on a
diet before my tour yeah that's at least
but what food is in England and Dublin I
just have to have stuff to be on a diet
when you're in tour though it's very
good when you're gonna eat yeah very
tough you can't really work out no Gibby
I'll need to diet used to keep your
skinny right now what are you walking
around up to forty I have no idea you
haven't weighed yourself you're not
weighing so do you not weigh yourself
because young people get too caught up
in it yeah I just worked out all the
time I healthy you kill me 9% of the
time unless it's dick dive Sunday and
then you know yeah it's a way to do it
what do you got chin symptom given good
chance here for all all OJ Simpson has a
pearl hearing this week and according to
everyone involved it seems as though
he's he's going to get it because he's
in there right for basically kidnapping
home solely against their will
yeah which I think only purchase
activity [ __ ] because they easily always
do it yeah well in Nevada they have very
very strong law so he was he they stole
his memorabilia he ran in there with
another guy and they had they held them
there at gunpoint that is kidnapping
according to Nevada law and AK I think
is a minimum of nine years something
right or somehow it's [ __ ] out here's
how long don't get me wrong I mean I'm
glad he did some time let's be real he
murdered two people however in this case
it's kind of [ __ ] up make through the
book Adam obviously we know why but if
you look at the case what happened where
these people had all [ __ ] that kind of
screwed him over he hired a guy to go on
there like kind of intimidate them with
a gun they had no intention of doing it
though yeah that was yeah he got
sentenced to a term of nine to thirty
three years ah see you know he killed
two people so I can see a bad guy yeah I
guess so seventy
years old he's 70 now Wow god damn Oh
Jason's in seven uncrazy
you know as soon as he gets out he
really has a reality show came out
really I lit a match all lined up I
forget what's net well I didn't know
that severoff offers and I will not be
watching that yeah well none of us we
want to have besides every every time we
come it will not be the highest rated
reality show of all time yeah yeah well
for the first three episodes and you
realize that he kind of sucks and hears
nothing talk about cuz I can talk about
like Nicole's you know he's gonna do
searching for the killers with all just
a bunch of honey [ __ ] oh yeah I saw
some over here yeah who's the killer
yeah well I hear about the book if I did
it gosh you know that even yes yes it's
so weird
it'll be a very interesting reality show
I would hope so I'm so I've watched that
OJ versus America the one that won the
Emmy all that stuff and where they
wouldn't oscar some [ __ ] where they went
all that stuff I've watched that
documentary
it's on Amy now it's on ESPN I see a
price seven times I need to see it where
can I get part series I tried looking
for it I couldn't find how can you not
find it what what you do go to Island on
Netflix right I'm Amy oh oh is it the
one that was on FX on Netflix you know I
look for no FX FX that's a TV show this
is the People vs OJ Simpson yes okay I
got to see my 30 ugh ESPN I bet would
have it Amy but it's on Netflix I tried
I look for it I couldn't find it type in
hey I'm a no Jay Simpson I did hey leave
me yeah go to oh then scroll over and
the Jay it will be the first thing I'm
pops up on the search engine I look good
normally your search history no no I'm
just not gonna grab some do I'm not not
saying I could I know you're gonna die
I'm not sitting yep oh sorry
there it is there it is yeah there's on
Netflix which says Oh jeepers the people
did you just search Oh Jay yeah John's
on first my know did I bring up but I
was you know you were gone for a while
sauce house sitting with Stevie okay
take it easy and I went through your to
search the engine and I saw some your
your history yeah I
it's whatever breath but I saw night I
saw a bunch like we had like see movies
like deep blue sea I saw guys when I got
the guys under a C's and then I saw that
that and then underneath I saw Brokeback
Mountain alright yeah and then I put I
well there's two deep diving movies
those guys I didn't eat yeah there's
Brokeback Mountain if a plus B equals C
I carefully see makes another sigh gasps
ah I [ __ ] knew it
ah I'm 50 you're 34 was the abyss
I remember this there's the bit yeah the
abyss yeah there's the bit yeah a bit
yeah yeah I like I like movies like that
going out at about you is the best and
then there is the deep blue sea yeah
yeah and then there was the shallows
right now yeah I was well deep yes what
do you write yeah
and underneath that was Brokeback man
and the next all of that was love story
would he try to Adelphia yeah which I
said and so if ABC equals MC what did
you dig do I get damn ass goddamn game
ass again that's the dick times I hate
that game ass there's no game ass bro
easy with that which well I mean alright
we've already offended everybody next
know what's up widowed with OJ he's
getting out though though they said that
everything he's been doing so far if he
wasn't OJ that would absolutely give
someone for all like anyone else would
qualify for it but the one thing that's
holding him back is obviously that he's
OJ is it weird that I want him out I was
just going to say that oh we've got
people how nice you love you tennis time
and I want him out
are we bad people this episode I mean
it's really I don't know that he does I
don't know if you wanna be part of my I
don't I don't know that more punishment
makes the world a better place and
changes anything I just feel like you
know there's at retribution I need to be
entertained let's let him out I feel the
same way and watch this [ __ ] show
yeah or he becomes hey hey OJ I've done
my neighborhood bro
he gets to play golf and goes back gets
back on top where's he comes on top
there's no on top
there's no top for him yeah tops just
getting out and was like there's no
money no money does you have no money I
thought you mention no man all that
money goes to Nicole although the
pension I said they can't touch yeah
because we need still not order still
not a lot of money is it three hundred
gram or four hundred I mean it's a lot
of money but not for lying for LA when
you're when you for him it's a lot of
money the way he live a mer would mean
with his life he'd been a [ __ ] sell
for the last nine years so I wonder if
he gave money he was selling memorabilia
that's a lot of money for him it's not
made for anyone yeah let's say making
five hundred grand you have to do [ __ ]
tax-free wanna fall from grace
two point five somewhere around 2.5
million you are great they're gonna pay
how much is he worth right now she's you
Oh Jay Simpson net worth
currently these are not really accurate
though foot not I can imagine that early
million yeah you gonna get out to me
[ __ ] show hey oj stay the [ __ ] down my
neighborhood though huh
don't say Barry I got acquitted for
murdering came back to brown whatever
was up they said he would like he'd be
filling up gas off San Vicente where I
was that yeah I was picturing I
definitely the new Bronco me get in
white for this exact reason but he'll be
filling up with gas and people drive by
talk to murder they said you just he'd
be it play golf with Brentwood Country
Club people just non-stop irascible damn
he can't kill people get away with and
be back to normal
goddamn crazy right looking a minor yes
I don't have that in me like I don't
have that need to like I always feel
like people I got are already paying a
price I'd be scared if I saw like he
killed two people I don't know
not me I wouldn't I would never add
insult to injury iris would you have him
on the phone the kid I would me to 100
percent what oh that only if you talked
about the murder
no I would Alohomora configure he's a
he's a he's a he's a uh uh in many ways
a Central American figure and a
representation not only of the American
dream but also the fall from grace
he's a gradual effect about me to
tragedy because well but well you would
talk to him Molly but the way you frame
a conversation with him is to talk about
being at the top falling funerals I'll
bring it and and you don't even have to
bring me I know he's uh bring in Chicago
right
no say whoa let's go okay yeah Sam Cisco
uh wouldn't he have gang leader no no I
thought you didn't game when he was
younger his black oh no no I read he was
in a gang nope
how about no he wasn't in getting but
his dad was uh gay when he found out
walked in on his dad wow man and turn
around and close friends like if anyone
says anything will kill both gang
intense cough yes and stuff yeah yeah I
would be close with his mom but his dad
his dad was a homosexual that's very
interesting very interesting I mean I
talked about be a lot to ask him and
talk to him about and you wouldn't have
to talk about the murders that's our
everybody knows that stuff yeah yeah but
I need details though like I would he
would did not mix but he would he'd
probably I'd be more interesting to hear
about how he deals with this XY and Z
you know I mean we're ready but if you
bring a manga what now you can get a
full [ __ ] John Jones on Joe Rogan
story did you can't you're not gonna buy
it it depends on how you frame it what
kind of conversation we know I'm saying
that's what you can get from him if you
go what now you didn't get a [ __ ]
story no I would ask him like I'll talk
football shank would you I think so
I'll talk about football we're waiting
to wear that now the concussions is he
worried about that growing up how he
played you talk about a complete freak
flourished football wise would secure it
with so fascinating to me and if you
watch that documentaries
he did a lot I kind of there's a lot of
signs of his age and I used today
egomaniac or sociopath but a lot of bad
stuff Ewing's young like he saw his
buddy with a girl again I can just took
her yeah they're getting [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
you out like Jesus
yeah there's a lot of bad my guess is
that he was definitely like it's feeling
he was associate but he's a sociopath
like he's a guy who doesn't really have
empathy for other people
there's that was also where he never he
always looked at himself and not as back
not as african-american but there's Oh
Jason yeah Mikey me he used derogatory
term towards black people and to anyone
so he had no actual day with only his
own sort of group until he got in
trouble until you gotta throw and watch
that and he tried use associated with
the blast yeah so then they said you'd
be in Brentwood he go to Beverly Hills
and I stress in Beverly Hills and walk
in like who the [ __ ] like these black
people and why the [ __ ] of the bike and
like oh my god man yeah you're black
yeah like hey heroes no I'm not emoji
it's like all right Wow
yeah strange [ __ ] man it's a fascinating
story though I think so too
I like incest having stories I think I
think that it'd be interesting Adam on
the podcast and that's it I mean you
know there's there is of course what he
did is unacceptable and everything they
said it something I'm not an interesting
team they said he had an appetite for
the lady that's correct
son lady that's correct I had no did he
chase ladies like he chased in zones
they said he was just quite crazy and
they also were very into him he was
younger he called it open it would dicta
yeah he had no problem taking down
hookers he wanted whatever you want to
anyone who they say him in kris
kardashian got it um whoo all right that
makes sense no we can imagine would be
like if they did she was how much she
was younger
young kris kardashian uh no but they did
say her not chris got it on for reals
I invited Alicia's daughter it's a
conspiracy theory but yeah don't say
she's bigger than all the other girls
she looks like OJ you bring up Chloe she
kind of does that's really interesting
keep checking my phone not to be rude
but what's her for like this and she run
the for $6 before she lost a long way
now yeah no she's
tractive one duduk just typing Chloe Oh
Jay Simpson Donna see what you get
still nothing pretty girl
yeah very attractive big girl but she's
big because the other ones are tiny yeah
right those are the daughters yes and
they look alike they all look alike I
don't buy it so we know that anyone
that's his actual dollar and that's
Chloe the side-by-side
oh oh I'm sorry Brian if they all look
alike look like the Kardashians that's
what Khloe Kardashian his actual
daughter but be kind of she kind of
looks like the other sister too though
this shorter one yeah bro got some room
we drop the rumour mill they say back
then the old Brent Brent would the rich
and elite just share dick yeah well
that's what Hollywood does uh I'd like
to be part of that all right let's get
me here I'm going to Oh what else you
got chin okay Australia they passed
legislation so in three years a pack of
cigarettes is gonna cost 40 bucks um Wow
although smokings free will and nearly
for help me down to it's about the only
way you could justify that the only way
is to say that smoking costs the state X
amount of dollars because we have to
take care of people when they get sick
when they're kids this is this is that
this attacks on your future death but I
think four dollars is way too much of a
stretch you know I kind of like it but I
hate smoking you know they say that the
generation now which is called what is
Generation X yeah general any answer no
I'm alone I mean I'm a gen Xer
I don't even know I thought it was
Generation X Generation X um no it's not
oh can you bring those final with the
Jenner but they're saying this
generation is going to end smoke it's
never been so low yeah that it's finally
here it's really pretty big in certain
parts the column is collimator yeah
because I don't see people smoking their
education here and we realize how bad as
they say this degeneration now is so yet
smoking again pipeline they have the
time generation Z by the time they have
kids it can be completely gone yeah
which is awesome well it's a [ __ ]
battery what am I then Jim what
generation of mine I don't know I I went
for a checkup and I'm 50 and the doctor
said you know he said do you smoke and I
said no I'm looking ever smoked us in
there he goes okay
he said not gonna check you for certain
thing I said what he goes well you know
mouth cancers bladder cancers there lots
of different cancers that are not long
related at all so you get weird cancers
like bladder cancer and that's all
exclusively almost that according to him
he said that's that you get bad with
smokers you don't get that with
Godfather cancer yeah like we're see you
a lot of cancers happen from smoking not
just lung cancer I'm John Generation Y
son um my thought would my pink eyes
want to be safe before I travel it's
finally going away think that so don't
freak out Arizona Phoenix or Salt Lake
it's gonna be gone not contagious either
anymore first two days I guess it is
anyways um I had I used that app called
heal they had the doctor to your house
right of you so this doctor came to my
house and they're usually don't you run
he was good but you basically just used
Google for everything
no way kinda like use Google like do you
did you get something you're I'm like
nah man it's pink I like to assume
doctors like all right um you know do
you have diarrhea I'm like dude what are
you doing and then you like symptoms
calm yeah like this severe so I'm like
come on bro fees but then he looked I
guess I got a few a few questions assets
I guess only sexual partners in the past
month what
all right now cuz it can be chlamydia
ball what so tell me have you had in the
past month I was like what the [ __ ] does
that dudes pink eyes it can be comitia
in your is really so pink I came off
times be chlamydia I don't realize that
no yes I will lines diagnosed pinkeye
before you spread it against you have
chlamydia in both eyes I don't think
that's true dude you've been pushing
your eyes you got too close to some of
these genitals to get a real good look
that is true actually is it yes yes 100%
no it doesn't mean you have it it can be
bacterial it cannot paint guy it can be
viral
but sometimes pinkeye can be the result
of actually the chlamydia of bacteria in
your eye you sound like a bro science
right no no a harder piece and you can
look it up there's no question chlamydia
King Khan Yes Doctor looks like after a
brother
yeah I thought of the instigators asked
about sexual partners it can 100% be yep
short answer is the sometimes how deep a
guy's not STD yep but it can be
bacterial viruses out on a Riyadh and
Clemente visits abroad Anglin things
with gonorrhea and gonorrhea
gonorrhea and chlamydia herpes a
allergic typical exposure looked other
types
Jayant papal Aries you can get a lot of
chemical allergic they they said really
might lease it easy the Haute I say in
the pillow
yeah or flying they don't not like they
really don't know like you go segment
travel out I went yeah and he goes will
they yeah first of all goes away on its
own usually after a week and to drop
yeah it's basically done young if it's
bacterial you know and a lot of times if
it's bacterial you should get possum
your eyes Tufts you just had really red
on yeah help us yeah
oh no no I don't oh that's got Jim he's
the reason big sever with his sanity you
might have gotten them from the sandler
on boots
alright a lot of gun from doing the
podcast because you've been diving on
you know you're the one with the samurai
boots and the ending STDs in your eyes
ah go for a bright china bands illegal
winning the poo means they're banning
winnie-the-pooh means because people
keep comparing way to poo to the Chinese
President hilarious and they actually
have these pictures there's some that
are really good so that one the one down
here I don't see the light I've never I
would know I look at him and go all that
looks like Winnie the Pooh but it just
it just caught fire and then everyone's
doing it so they actually they're
banning it they're going night
I know so Doakes quit doing that China
but funny
hey China hey [ __ ] in China it's not
funny let us get chin check this up drag
by subway in Rome Italy some woman you
know how they put their purses on there
like around their body on her shoulders
it scares like a sack like a sack she
went into the Train and then got the
doors closed so she try to get out and
she got dragged I'll show you the video
did she live yes she lived so you see
her the door closes on her purse she
can't get out for sure get the clerk
alone for sure take the purse off it no
it's wrapped around the kitchen dig get
out of it oh my god hey help her
[ __ ]
I'm not gonna do now they pulled that
emergency brake too but it didn't work
and the driver the engineer he was
actually eating and he didn't see her as
it went down so she she got released
there near the Ixia the second stop all
has broken bones and all but she
survived oh she was broken bones yeah
got scared the [ __ ] out of me man
I don't like seeing that like a lot of
things went wrong there the door
shouldn't have done that
the the brake thing didn't work you want
a night to cut that [ __ ] kurta I'm
gonna start carrying a knife in case
just don't wear a satchel like that it
should be all right yeah just one shake
accident stuck yeah should happen boss
she's I [ __ ] yeah it's funny if she
didn't died she got flat flat again
anybody thing oh [ __ ] alright enough
this jutsu
alright a dog ran into a lake in Long
Island to save a baby deer from drowning
and and the dog died literally so he's
used the dogs all the way inside the
lake he's familiar yeah I think that
dogs trying to kill that deer host the
ocean I thought it was like that looks
like a lake yeah we don't here would be
no [ __ ] huh yes you see the dog dragging
this little baby deer back my head so my
feeling is especially comes up well he's
trying to kill that guy I see what's
happening let's it go and watch this the
deer gets up and he's like nudging the
deer to run Oh cute
and then watch so the the deer falls
down again here in this motionless but
I'm just great sashing do then he does a
wheat it's weird right so I don't know
if the hog was you that does not earn it
well well you know chew on his ear okay
no he's just kind of like oh the old top
I love it and get him go charging him
that's so sweet
he's actually saving him I would have
the dares like the exhaust I I mean I I
think that deer so cute but that's good
eating is that real I'd have to bring a
ripe I have to take him back for a
little swim and be like you know what
you didn't really quite make em will
hold you but I have to hold you under
cuz you don't want to look too lazy made
out of the ocean but the old right in
the snout I've always wanted to do that
I do that to dogs you want to cover his
nose over their nose last a second now I
would ask the dark side in me by
whenever I see a dog you suffice with
squeeze or nose I go what happened if I
discovered nice Lord and then I can jump
on I don't kill them and try to feel
them out
no dad when you're sleeping and to me a
close your mouth my I would have to take
it right back out me these super he's
Finders Keepers you know I'm saying amen
first of all I scold my dog for saving
that thing because I got I gotta eat a
boy's got eat and fawn is delicious when
it dies absolutely lost human dies of
natural causes meaning water water deer
cause after the deer got up he ran back
into the freakin water and then I said
they had to get a rescue people whatever
crew come out there and then then
finally they got him and took him to
like a veterinary why'd you keep runnin
bison order dispatch mom like across the
other side they did did you think about
walking around for God well first of all
deers probably don't think they have
tiny brains so yeah but I said head but
you just deers don't go into the water
especially animals died well I was
hunting him under in Missouri and they
[ __ ] they swam right across the river
I have enough video on that meat-eater
thing yes longer Listeria and all the
whole family was just got in the water
I'm like about to come up and they just
get in the water and they swim to the
other side and I'm not a lot of shoot
goes on that side I'm gonna shoot bucks
I was like are you kidding me and my
guide
Calahan go still think dere's dump but
get off it oh yeah only when I'm talking
my fingers in your zone do not dare to
call out your Harmon Dupin you don't
feel all my body searching the one time
you went hunting this is my I hear bass
for the last six years this is my zero
anybody can go hunting again for some
new Stu I have been hunting street I'm
sorry for I can't remember and - how
dare you touch my personal hey you know
Michael Phelps is racing a great white
shark he's back he's boring and so are
sharks alright next vet how dare you I
will put these thing as the minnows just
popped out just popped out Michael hey
he's got a super short legs and a really
long torso his long legs
it's always very very short no no no his
legs are belong on a five foot seven man
you guys limping I know he's got really
short legs reasoning so good is because
it's like his son's brain is Zoomer I
know that but look at me Hey look at me
very short legs very long torso in that
big boy you are good where do you use
one know you nursed one know you dig
dive another 12 arey big gums listen me
he's all torso hey what I don't
understand and it's a really happening
how is Michael Phelps in rates a great
white in the great white just doesn't go
I'm going to eat you like how are they
keep them in line maybe they're
indifferent yeah they have to be case if
someone has to be you can't you can't
cage a great one of the Michael Phelps
and I don't know they have to put them
in some sort of it has to right yeah but
then how do you get the great white to
swim assess the camera it's so dumb I
don't know or is it all let you know how
it's all electronic it's all stupid like
yeah he's gonna be in a pool a great
white to me notion they're like well
this is a great white if he's chasing a
seal week at a time here so great white
[ __ ] a great white crush him in a race
so what a min oh yeah right I mean you
know living betta though
well I'm really good the odds I put
Michael Vaz work sharper you got shut up
swimming is Tom attention to him I'm in
Yellin bully Michael Phelps gets
attention really it's always been really
popular sport swimming Shark Week it's
only 30
how are we doing this I've raced the
fastest summers on the climate oh he he
did series I travel third he's in a cage
there I prepared for hours in the open
water with a month and increase my speed
my fast another show watch with me to
find out builds Bruce York [ __ ] oh
yes first of all you're making yourself
look like a big old fish so good luck
with that
in that look for ocean supremacy yeah
right like I did you're not you need to
know I'm hey not a card to like oh my
painting on it with a vengeance it's the
dumbest [ __ ] in the that's ever been on
TV and also I'm not watching it even if
he beats him even if it's incredibly
even he gets eaten I'm boycotting it I'm
not watching it and also great whites
pasture of course so be quiet will see
my faceted a shark you shut everybody up
when he hey I'll take Michael Phelps
chances now we'll see no sir Michael
Phelps could be mean the truth is a
great way I could be swimming in the
water and Usain Bolt could be running
and guess who wins this is the real
question what's good easy who wins my
brain hurts because this is [ __ ]
studio if Michael Phelps on land first
know so so no I say oh you sound boat
running top speed a white shark and
water glands who wins Lynn who wins
great white correct even in water even
with all I residual four-year-old
listeners are going great white sir but
that's kind of crazy
okay look at how fast they can swim
3,000 miles an hour forty mile a mile 25
miles an hour
ah Usain Bolt would beat them hashtag
right full of [ __ ] ah could be a tie
mako sharks are the ones Makos are
fastest [ __ ] no true waste of time now
he swims like six half miles now who
gives a [ __ ] 25 miles an hour yeah
matter of fact who same boat with Beatle
you saying it's a hit hits what 27 miles
an hour so I'm crazy
who's saying both yeah I don't know
what's not being crazy
it is MP 12 miles an hour twenty seven
point seven miles per hour
I'm seeing boat beetle yeah and the
other bring by two miles an hour
barely [ __ ] and besides I'm teen every
great white mako shark would crush him
though put how fast a mako shark rode
swim Makos are [ __ ] fast
get ready dude get ready ah 600 miles an
hour tailings oh [ __ ] think about that
in the water
what think about that their shark any a
moment in other news there's sharks what
else yet you in rare footage kid came
out an hour mako shark have you seen
that it's a short go like this no you
don't know not seen them then a cheetah
to the ocean yeah move on [ __ ] please
watch that please come back into that
it's blue not cingulum no lure zoom you
know that's why the viewers want it
viewers want this dick diver they can't
see it though oh yeah they can although
he's going me ass out of it everybody
wish you could see this what the Frick
this thing is really moving man what
does the rash swimmers in the water it's
going quick I said that's my rule and
they'll just turn on I mean it's really
kicking its tail guys it's wiggling
through the water what else yet June how
about myself actors Eric 23 is accused
of killing both his way my Chris talk
about OJ Simpson Ali [ __ ] plunge just
see what you're doing
gotcha and read this not go ahead so
last year a guy a son and his mother
sink a boat and the son got those little
crazy life raft things out and the
mother disappeared right so they found
the Sun after a week in the water and
then uh this is the son he has
Asperger's he also has a grandfather
that died a few years back in 2013 or
something what by a gunshot wound and
that same caliber bullet was the one
that he had or he bought but they
couldn't recover so they're thinking
that this dude he looks like a sociopath
he's an Asperger's - he's like trying to
you know inherit the money that his
grandfather had his grandfather was a
millionaire so the mother missing there
feeling like he did that on purpose yeah
44 million whoa
name's Nathan Christian was suspect in
his grandfather's death and high Athenry
of 87 year-old real estate developer was
shot and killed his Vermont home into
him 87 a good run so three of his answer
are suing him right now [ __ ] we got him
right there I didn't need to see the
case he did it I hate when you know what
how the other Derek it was gonna be so
funny you say that I completely think he
did it I did I just looking at Vaughn
you look like [ __ ] you guys do kudos
he's a little longer on one side to the
other just for that you should go to
jail man he's not a bad-looking kid
either he's not a great you'll 44 mil as
burgers mmm interesting hey would you
let me shoot you in the f40 no no cuz it
would give me a it would give me pain
for the rest of my life and I'm only
forty four million dollars and I need a
suggestion I name he could shoot me in
the ass of the desert yeah oh you
couldn't belong you might have a length
rest realignment what yeah you'll also
might be with a limp and a clerestory
Richie [ __ ] with a cane I get 44 million
the bacons breakdown shot me mad I
wouldn't do it I need my morality bro I
need to be able to pump hard cuz man I
[ __ ] dudes ah damn it
what ljh ah oh god I got caught again
one more all right
another teacher yeah it's busted fraud a
sex with the team so and she's blaming
or her lawyers blaming mental illness
yeah why aren't I bring her warning for
birthday Horning the mental illness is
depression and work stress so she took
it on the kids dick yeah and wrong with
it
let her there is cuz they're underage
but I know but they're dudes when I was
16 I was a kid huh they're kids
like seven my six-year-old nephew I was
with him last night he's my he saw my
sister-in-law and he goes who is that
who's that girl I go
my my sister-in-law he goes she's so
freaking hot I go hey bro that's what
sixteen year olds do I don't
he couldn't take his eyes off her she's
35 that's her she's hot
because we're all hot of another time
here's III approve he shead debauched a
minor oh oh yeah that was that was the
legal term D bout the box it's law to me
ask you this B yeah your son Finn is 14
yeah Tim Tommy was dad you know you miss
Clarkson yeah yeah English - yeah yeah
yeah
she told me to come see that school and
I [ __ ] her yeah Jimmy cool with it
watch watch this I go like this don't
tell your mother
it's what he thinks okay I go I want you
to high-five me don't tell you about the
filming next time I fight him enjoy that
and I want you to ask her if she's into
the old man and when you're done wanna
know I got something over you hey I know
you can keep a secret
I could watch your no trip my way
otherwise it would rap on Bullock yeah
you like you like you like my son 14 how
about how about how about adding about
35 years on that god when your son 14
you'll be I'll be a thousand to be 64 oh
my god I'll be 64 years old
oh no he's held right now that he's five
so I'll be at 66 I'll be you 6161
right 59 59 yeah yeah you get this yeah
b9 but I'm gonna be a young 59 cos boxer
tennis player [ __ ] dick oh oh oh oh
yeah dropping oh it's worse
yeah yeah I actually really interesting
that I change makes others idea of art
and I love this idea for you as a person
so you've heard me say many times that
it's not it's it's mental toughest days
learning what not to think about
sometimes learn what not to think about
don't worry about what to think about
sometimes when you take out the things
you're not you shouldn't think about the
important things will find their way in
but there's a great
metaphor for art and for who you could
be as a person there's a book by Irving
stone called the agony and the ecstasy
and it's a classic book and it's written
about the life and times of Michelangelo
the great artist who painted the Sistine
Chapel and he is considered one of the
greatest artists of all time
and one of the great figures of all time
and when he was about to carve the
Statue of David the Devi which still
stands I think in Milan or Florence
actually uh he was going to eat what he
would do is he would go to going like
literally in the morgue and touch
cadavers and and study them and feel
them so he could turn the marble and
just what he called me where it looked
like it was a living and he was a great
sculptor and he took this huge statue
and he took this giant giant piece of
marble and somebody asked him the legend
goes how are you going to do this and he
said well it's already in there it so it
was just a giant block of marble and he
said it'd be sculpture is already in
there I just have to get all the stuff
out of the way and it's a great way of
looking at art or even yourself you
you're the perfect you has already
already exists it's a question of
getting all the [ __ ] out of the way
and I never forgot that and I've always
used that as a marker to live my life
thank you and hold my hand thank you
thank you yeah else's after dick done
you have to do the whole Joe Harrison
yes this go to touch my hand I'll look
and at the minute my hand closes on your
head that's when you have to call me to
gravity' and I've always said that
that's had a gentleman actually had a
dive I've got a Mike Tyson cancels on
his big dog I got you they just said he
can do two o'clock he knows you two I
know how does that know thank you so
much we tried cuz we'll come in and
he'll cancel my did you know the show's
doing well Mike Tyson's come on your
show yes any listen for him to come on
yep yeah that's really cool because we
didn't reach out to him no they reached
out to us so that's always a good in the
transplant and they try to reschedule it
it works like that Michael is on the
podcasting welcome podcast and I got
some stuff we'll figure out there all
right ladies and gentlemen uh anything
else buddy were you gonna be
I wouldn't ghosts going up ah who knows
what doesn't matter you know what
doesn't matter we'll be where we'll be
will be either in Montero will be where
we'll be where we'll be shows sold out
we'll be where we'll be god Bless You
America this is the finally kid your
dick diver we're out